very distressing news here um
this is from media matters
it says
headline
amazon's best-selling lgbtq book is a
hateful picture book comparing being
trans to pretending to be a walrus
the best-selling lgbtq plus book on
amazon is johnny the walrus a hateful
picture book by the daily wires matt
walsh that compares the gender
identities of trans youth to a young boy
who imagines he's a walrus
amazon mislabeled the book into its
lgbtq book section and as a result it's
promoting harmful anti-trans views to
its consumers interested in lgbtq
stories
um and then they go on
this is this is outrageous and very
upsetting for me
and i was worried that this would happen
that this kind of homophobia and gay
erasure would happen
but for media matters to be doing it is
beyond the pale
for them to be going after and attacking
the most prominent the most revered the
most respected and beloved and
best-selling lgbt author not just in the
nation but in the world okay amazon they
don't say these are the books selling in
america this is the world and i'm still
number one i've been number one i've
been the best selling lgbt book for a
week
and i put my heart and soul into that
book and and with with the objective and
the goal of getting on that list
so that i could represent the lgbt
community as its most prominent
figure and speaker uh
and yet i'm being attacked in this way
it it's
very very upsetting to me
shame on you media matters
and uh glad the gay and lesbian alliance
against defamation they've joined in
okay these media matters
the gay lesbian alliance against
defamation you should be on my side i'm
the one being defamed as the number one
most prominent best-selling lgbt author
in the country in the world
but they're coming out against me and
they put out this way they say this is
horrible
amazon please remove this book from the
lgbtq category immediately
it is absolutely not an lgbtq book it
specifically targets transgender people
with hateful and dehumanizing rhetoric
where can i turn now
as
the leading voice
as my generation's leading voice in the
lgbt community
where can i turn i can't turn to glad i
can't turn to media matters
i'm a man without a home i'm a man on an
island
um let's read a little bit more from
this
johnny the walrus is an anti-trans
allegory that compares a child imagining
that he's a walrus to society affirming
and accepting trans youth
including by providing life-saving best
practice medical care when kids go
through puberty
in reality now i just want to point out
okay i the word transgender does not
appear in a book at any point
so if you read the book and you think
there might be similarities between
what we do with quote unquote trans kids
and a kid pretending to be a walrus i
mean if you are drawing those
connections and connecting those dots
maybe you should think a little bit
more about that
and
the description of the children's book
claims that it is about a little boy
with a big imagination named johnny who
forced to make a decision between the
little boy he is and the things he
pretends to be
the book depicts johnny first pretending
to be a walrus by using wood spoons as
tusks and socks as fins then going
through the process of trying to become
a walrus by eating worms putting on gray
makeup and visiting a doctor who offers
a simple procedure to cut his feet into
fins
notably amazon has faced backlash for
selling anti-trans books in the past
the company continues to sell the book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters by
anti-trans author abigail schreier even
though employees of amazon filed an
internal complaint in april claiming
that the book violates the company's
policy against selling books that frame
lgbtq identities as a mental illness
um
and uh then it goes on okay so they're
they're very upset
they're very upset that the book exists
they're very very upset that it got on
the lgbt list
which was amazon's call not mine
but i'm honored by it
and uh and this is what they're doing
rampant homophobia over at media matters
disgraceful if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends